[Música]
también respalda y que nos dice que son
6,4
[Música]
yo me contactaba con el sargento
y yo le decía quiero chivos
quiero dos chivos porque quiero hacerle
un asado
[Música]
a mi gente a mi pelotón
esas eran las palabras claves
esos dos chidos serán los cielos que
vamos a asesinar
entre 2002 y 2008 miles de colombianos
fueron asesinados por el ejército para
ser presentados como guerrilleros
muertos en combate en la jerga militar
se les llama falsos positivos
sí estamos haciendo un mural
los representando los
6.402
donde en falsos positivos
mal llamados falsos positivos
ejecuciones extrajudiciales
a mi hijo y a mi sobrino
salieron en una tarde a dar una vuelta
comienzan un helado y nunca jamás
volvieron
fueron torturados disfrazados
Doris Tejada es una de estas madres que
exigen Justicia La mayoría de estos
crímenes continúan en la impunidad
en el mural las caras de una docena de
generales en los años 2000 sus
batallones cometieron en mayor número de
falsos positivos para inflar las
estadísticas de guerrilleros abatidos
13 ya aumentaron más
porquerías 13 porquerías
[Música]
lo que quieren las víctimas es que ellos
le digan la verdad no solamente a las
víctimas sino al país de Quiénes son los
máximos responsables que si solo
generales si son los ministros de
defensa si es el presidente Uribe que
era el que estaba en esa época de
presidente
horas más tarde estas caras serán
borradas
luego que es hora de la escuela quién
sabe qué Porque Qué tan lejos viene de
allá hasta acá y aprovechan es diga
usted tipo 10 de la noche hasta las 4 de
la mañana
el ejército sigue sin reconocer el
escándalo de los falsos positivos un
tema todavía tabú en Colombia
a principios del Siglo 21 el país está
sumido en la guerra la guerrilla de las
FARC controló la parte del territorio
sus enemigos los paramilitares siembran
en terror a menudo con la complicidad
del ejército de Colombia en 2002 Álvaro
Uribe es elegido presidente con la
promesa de acabar con la guerrilla
implementa su política de seguridad los
años siguientes son los de una dura
ofensiva militar los resultados se miden
en el número de guerrilleros muertos en
2008 es talla el escándalo
en noticias uno esta noche atención en
las últimas horas fueron capturados en
el tolima 11 soldados profesionales
acusados de matar cinco Civiles para
presentarlos como bajas en combate las
madres aseguran que sus hijos
aparecieron muertos en ocaña horas
después de desaparecer en Bogotá lo
único que me dijo era que se iba a
encontrar con una persona para ir a
hablarlo de un trabajo
los crímenes son atribuidos a unas pocas
manzanas podridas el prestigio de las
fuerzas armadas de Colombia en el
corazón del pueblo y en la comunidad
internacional no puede mancharse por los
delitos
por las fallas administrativas que
algunos de sus integrantes cometa
las primeras víctimas halladas venían de
los barrios populares de soacha un
municipio al sur de Bogotá
Aquí tengo el rostro de Oscar
le puse este borde azul amarillo azul y
rojo de Colombia
nuestra Colombia que ha masacrado tanta
tanta gente
Oscar vivía con nosotros tenía 26 años
en el 2007 Oscar Estaba sin empleo se
fue a vender ropa como trabajador
informal en la ciudad de Cúcuta en la
frontera con Venezuela
él se desapareció el 31 de diciembre del
2007 Porque eran las 11 de la noche
cuando nosotros hablamos con él Entonces
desde ahí desde ese momento ya él se
desapareció no volvimos a saber nada más
de
la familia denunció su desaparición su
rastro fue encontrado en 2011
llegué al cti y la señorita
Doña Doris ya lo encontramos
y está en una fosa común
él fue en tuvo un enfrentamiento con el
ejército lo que uno menos quiere oír
menos que entonces yo dije no es un
enfrentamiento si él no está pagando
servicio él no estaba en
desde entonces luchan por recuperar su
cuerpo se cree que los militares lo
sepultaron en una fosa común aún sin
Localizar a 500 kilómetros del lugar de
su desaparición
destruye en la familia
todos son jóvenes
que que ayudan a las familias
inocentes porque le faltaban pantalones
para enfrentar los guerrilleros para
enfrentar la gente que les respondía con
armas
le faltaron pantalones son cobardes
mi hijo era una persona muy increíble
muy correcta le enseñamos muy buenos
valores
[Música]
míralo ahí
poco a poco Colombia descubre que la
macabra práctica afecta a todo el país
los falsos positivos se cuentan por
cientos luego por miles
en el sistema judicial colombiano Los
juicios son dilatados o archivados solo
una ínfima parte de los culpables son
encarcelados simples soldados o
suboficiales
diez años después la jurisdicción
especial para la paz la jep se hace
cargo del caso producto del acuerdo de
paz con la guerrilla de las FARC este
tribunal de Justicia restaurativa se
encarga de juzgar los crímenes de todos
los actores del conflicto
es una Nueva Visión de la justicia
la misión de la jefe es la de
estabilizar la paz en Colombia y uno de
los peores crímenes que se cometió en el
conflicto armado interno colombiano fue
justamente las ejecuciones
extrajudiciales
las primeras investigaciones en
profundidad de la jurisdicción han
señalado que en efecto se trata O se
trató de una política sistemática no
fueron simplemente manzanas podridas
sino una actuación organizada en el
interior de aparatos de poder que se
incrustaron dentro de las fuerzas
militares
retoma los expedientes de la justicia
ordinaria y lleva a cabo sus propias
investigaciones gracias a los
testimonios de víctimas y acusados
quienes cuenten toda la verdad no
cumplirán penas de cárcel sino trabajos
comunitarios y actos de reparación a las
víctimas
al principio del 2021 la jep de sus
primeros resultados para el caso
003 el de las ejecuciones de civiles por
agentes del Estado
anuncia un número de víctimas sin
precedentes tres veces mayor que el
censo anterior entre ellas el hijo de
Doris
Mi nombre es María Doris Tejada madre de
Oscar Alexander Morales Tejada yo soy
una de las mamitas
de mapapo de madres falsos positivos mi
hijo en estos momentos Todavía está en
una fosa común
sin encontrarlo 13 años luchando para
encontrarlo
voy a lograrlo gracias
[Música]
hoy nos encontramos aquí en las
instalaciones de la jep Porque queremos
venir a apoyar y respaldar esa ese
comunicado que ellos hicieron hace un
par de semanas de los seis mil
cuatrocientos dos casos ya documentados
ante la jep
[Música]
este fue el montaje que le hicieron a mi
hermano
Él le preguntó a ellos Quién quiere
disparar ninguno quiso disparar Entonces
él
él fue el que lo mató
le colocaron armas
Mire le pusieron sus botas le colocaron
dos botas izquierdas
le colocaron más armamento
y me lo hicieron de guerrillero
[Música]
en las audiencias se hablan de altos
mandos pero cuando los altos mandos
llegan a hablar no no saben que es un
falso positivo
terminan
echándole toda la culpa a los de a los
de menor Rango
durante la pandemia de Kobe 19 las
audiencias de la jurisdicción especial
para la paz se realizan de forma virtual
en videoconferencia los familiares de
las víctimas leen su testimonio ante los
magistrados
Mi nombre es Jacqueline Castillo soy la
representante legal del colectivo de
mafapo hermana de Jaime Castillo Peña
muerto el 12 de agosto del 2008 en ocaña
norte de Santander como guerrillero dado
de baja en combate junto con los jóvenes
de soacha
buenas tardes
esto ha sido duro para mí estos 13 años
yo no he podido todavía aceptar la
muerte de mis hijos de mi hijo
la primera responsabilidad que tiene el
presidente de la república el señor
Álvaro Uribe el ministro de defensa de
la época a mí me tocó por ejemplo en
soacha iba a [__] colectivo para irme
para mi trabajo donde había un grupo de
varios de varias personas diciendo no
pero es que los muchachos de soacha que
mataron allá en ocaña eran unos
guerrilleros porque el señor presidente
dijo pero muy abusivamente separarse
pero en un medio de comunicación a decir
que los jóvenes no no se habían ido
precisamente a [__] café sino al
reintegra alrededor de ocaña la lucha es
dura la lucha es grande porque estamos
peleando con un monstruo de siete
cabezas que es Álvaro Uribe
[Música]
de nuevo muchas gracias a ustedes por
volver a confiar en nosotros
aquí estamos tratando de hacer lo mejor
posible nuestros mejores esfuerzos para
hacer justicia
para las familias la jurisdicción
especial para la paz abre la esperanza
de que por fin se castigue a todos los
culpables tras años de parálisis en los
tribunales
Sebastián forma parte de un colectivo de
abogados de víctimas de crímenes de
estado representa a la familia de Doris
aquí en mis manos tengo dos de las 12
carpetas que tiene la fiscalía general
de la nación en la investigación del
homicidio de Oscar Alexander Morales
Tejada a manos del ejército nacional de
Colombia aquí solo tenemos los que
cometieron el hecho criminal o Los que
participaron en el hecho criminal
quienes faltan quienes dieron parte de
la orden los acusados son siete soldados
y dos suboficiales según ellos Oscar fue
abatido con otros dos jóvenes durante
una operación militar contra un grupo
armado
si uno toma el expediente y analiza
estas versiones uno se puede dar cuenta
de graves contradicciones entre ellos
el caso nunca se resolvió a pesar de las
pruebas en contra del ejército
realizando la inspección del cadáver de
Oscar Alexander Morales se encontraron
un fusil acá 47 con su proveedor se le
hace una prueba de residuos para
establecer si efectivamente había
disparado las armas el arma que es la
k-47 y se demuestra que no no había sido
disparada por él los mismos
jefes de sección de inteligencia Y
operaciones han confesado no solo el
caso de Oscar
sino otros 33 otras 33 víctimas todas
son falsas en la región de valledupar en
el norte de Colombia opera el batallón
la popa fue una de las guarniciones más
sanguinarias
de valledupar era una verdadera máquina
de la muerte entre los años 2012 y 2005
así lo señalamos ex integrantes de esa
unidad militar ante la jurisdicción
especial para la paz por lo menos 127
asesinatos y desapariciones habrían
cometido miembros del Batallón la popa
de valledupar en apenas dos años y medio
de operaciones la recompensa
unas gotas
que me ayudan a tranquilizar mucho
y donde pierda pues poquito el control
me desestabilice me las tomaré debajo de
la lengua en un hotel de valledupar
Doris se prepara para regresar a la
escena del crimen de su hijo Óscar
muerto en 2008 bajo las balas del
Batallón la popa
la acompañan su esposo su hija
familiares de víctimas defensoras de los
derechos humanos y su abogado
Óscar y los dos jóvenes asesinados con
él fueron transportados de Cúcuta a el
copei a más de 500 kilómetros de
distancia
según la investigación de los abogados
cayeron en la trampa mortal del ejército
al aceptar una Falsa promesa de trabajo
probablemente como jornaleros en una
finca
en el coupey Doris descubre que el lugar
donde estaría enterado su hijo está
cubierto por una construcción que
dificultará la búsqueda
ahí vienen unas familias que son las que
vienen de acá
el municipio está construyendo aquí un
cementerio
en los años 2000 decenas de Muertos
anónimos del conflicto fueron sepultados
en algún lugar de este amplio terreno
muchos eran falsos positivos
la jurisdicción para la paz ordenó
detener las obras a la espera de una
excavación
se decía que los resultados se miden con
litro de sangre
decían que Las capturas no servían
o sea tocaba qué litros de sangre por
eso merecen esas familias la verdad
cuando se han resultados operacionales
se van permisos
personas de que en pelotones duraban
cuatro cinco siete meses en el monte
sin ver a sus seres queridos
este hombre era suboficial en el
batallón en la popa
aceptó dar su testimonio en Bogotá con
la condición de mantener el anonimato
ya ingresé al ejército en el año 2005
ingresé por amor a la patria
mi familia era de bajos recursos no me
podían brindar una universidad
después de una falta disciplinaria debía
presentar resultados sino sería
despedido
y ahí donde yo empiezo a coordinar
con el sargento de inteligencia Y con el
mayor
Las bajas en combate que se iban a
realizar
con el sargento inteligencia él era el
que buscaba
él tenía el contacto
para traer a las personas engañadas
un
ser y después murió en extraños hechos
en una camioneta del Batallón creo que
se quedó Aparentemente sin frenos
el reclutador Busca las víctimas
Mediante los engaños de que hay una
promesa de trabajo para una finca para
recoger café ese reclutador los trae
a los puntos donde se van a realizar
esas ejecuciones
en mi caso
los traen a la ciudad yo lo recojo
en qué lo recojo
en una camioneta
A quién estaba asignada
al Coronel y al mayor les decimos que
ellos no van a trabajar
recogiendo café que ellos han sido
reclutados para las autodefensas Unidas
y que por lo tanto ahí tienen sus
uniformes
y decimos que vamos a hacer una práctica
de tiro
se distancian las dos personas a las
cuales hacían hacer asesinadas una en un
punto otra en un punto
cubierta por la maleza de la zona
y soldados que sabían lo que íbamos a
hacer bajo las órdenes
de los comandantes
asesinarlos
dispara uno y dispara el otro
Y así fue
el suboficial no participó en el
asesinato del hijo de Doris sin embargo
en muchos casos la puesta en escena era
la misma
Óscar morales y sus dos compañeros de
infortunio fueron asesinados al borde de
una carretera rural lejos del pueblo en
su memoria Doris y sus compañeros van a
plantar árboles ahí este fue el sitio en
que reportaron el supuesto combate que
la descripción había sido que antes de
la curva
habían venido
según algunos militares 10 personas para
otros militares 20 pero en últimas
supuestamente los tres muchachos y unos
habían caído uno había caído este lado
el lado del Río
en el nombre del Padre del Hijo y del
Espíritu Santo
papito Dios
dame fuerzas para
seguir este caminar
por nuestros desaparecidos
minuto de silencio toda una vida de
lucha
por la memoria
[Música]
contra la impunidad la impunidad y hasta
encontrarse
las víctimas
en todo proceso hacen parte de población
vulnerable
son los barrios
con bajos recursos económicos El Ladrón
Del Barrio
la persona con alguna discapacidad
mental
se ataca la vulnerabilidad la falta de
oportunidad de empleo y la educación
Quién es la orden a ver
si si organizamos esto
en un orden jerárquico
entonces iniciemos con ese programa o
que en ese punto de la seguridad
democrática
estamos bajo el gobierno
de Álvaro Uribe Vélez
en el ejército estaba Mario Montoya
Gabriel Rincón era teniente coronel de
la décimo quinta división del ejército
encargado de las operaciones varido
informes falsos en los casos de
ejecuciones de civiles cometidas por su
unidad Se declaró culpable ante la jep
conocí a mi general Montoya
y él era el comandante El Comando
conjunto del Caribe
el primer encaramiento que él me hace
que usted tiene que también Mostrarme
resultados a manera jocosa dijo
consigase unos camuflados
saque unos muertos y preséntelos yo no
le paré bolas pero sí causó una gran
extrañeza porque
a qué obedece el que me haga ese tipo de
insinuaciones
el general Mario Montoya es el oficial
de mayor Rango que ha comparecido ante
la jurisdicción especial para la paz
niega toda responsabilidad en la masacre
de civiles
pero muchos testigos cuestionan sus
métodos
Mario Montoya fue uno de los pilares de
la política de seguridad del presidente
Álvaro Uribe de 2006 a 2008 es
comandante del ejército la presión sobre
los oficiales es constante
y el paso por frente de cada uno Cuántos
cuánto llevan la unidad y Cuántos
muertos en combate lleva y nos dio plazo
de que si en menos de un mes no
comenzamos a responder
resultados nos hacía relevar del cargo y
nos echaba muchos comandantes no
quisieron participar de eso y
prefirieron irse
afortunado ellos que se fueron
desafortunadamente y desafortunado
nosotros que nos quedamos porque
entonces comenzamos a tener una
conciencia y asimilar un rol
que ha sido la vergüenza más grande para
este país
existe hoy una especie de pacto de
silencio en el ejército colombiano
los ex militares que testifican ante la
jep lo hacen poniendo su vida en peligro
el coronel Rincón fue objeto de un
intento de asesinato de asignaron un
vehículo blindado y dos guardaespaldas
[Música]
en las sesiones públicas de la
jurisdicción para la paz cada vez más
exmilitares admiten sus crímenes ante
las víctimas en cuatro años más de 600
militares han sido escuchados algunos
generales y coroneles empiezan a
declararse culpables revelando cada vez
más el alcance del escándalo
junto con katarina Díaz y Alejandro
rameli Oscar Parra es uno de los
magistrados de la jep encargados del
caso
[Música]
lo que hemos hecho es explotar las
herramientas que nos da la justicia
transicional para impulsar un
esclarecimiento profundo de la verdad
Pero también escenarios de diálogos
restaurativos y todo eso nos ha
permitido
nos ha permitido aportar en romper con
el negacionismo que en muchos durante
muchos años caracterizó la respuesta
institucional Estatal poco a poco
nuestros avances
ratifican
el soporte probatorio de estas
constataciones sobre la generalidad del
fenómeno
la sistematicidad de los hechos y ese
conjunto amplio de responsabilidades que
iremos decantando poco a poco la
investigación durará varios años más
después un tribunal para la paz dictar a
las sentencias Quienes no digan la
verdad se enfrentan a penas de hasta 20
años de prisión
la jep no tiene la facultad para juzgar
a un expresidente Álvaro Uribe y su
ministro de defensa Juan Manuel Santos
por ahora no están siendo investigados
las madres siguen preguntando Quién dio
la orden
continúa en su lucha marcada por
rituales para llevar este Duelo
imposible
[Música]
allí donde vamos a ir vamos a lavar
a lavar nuestras heridas
alabar todos nuestros Dolores
para seguir caminando
en ese transinar que es bien largo y
bien difícil
[Música]
en el país la unidad de búsqueda de
personas desaparecidas localizó las
fosas comunes e inició excavaciones en
el terreno donde podría estar enterado
el hijo de Doris se encontraron unos 40
cadáveres
identificarlos podría tomar años
el escándalo de los falsos positivos es
solo uno de los oscuros episodios del
interminable conflicto colombiano en
total desde 1985 han muerto más de
450.000 personas y 120.000 han
desaparecido
[Música]
[Aplausos]